all right people this is it we're back
in business it's january 10th
2022. i am florida man dave rubin and
yes
we are in florida we are on rumble on
youtube on blaze tv and you may be
wondering what's going on here dave how
could you be
in florida that looks like your
background
but through the magic of the internet
and technology that's actually a fake
background it's just a screen behind me
it's not the old studio we couldn't
actually move the house
we are at newsmax studios here in
florida they are letting us use their
studios for a week i am hugely
appreciative
of my buddy john bachman and the entire
newsmax team hooking us up
i was gonna go
to dallas over to the blaze studios this
week to shoot over there at first
because it's taken us a little time to
build out our temporary studio and we
haven't closed on the house yet blah
blah blah it's all good
but i really felt that it was important
that i get back into the studio and do
it from
florida because uh so much of my life is
now
about florida so i'm super psyched to be
back in studio there's a ton of stuff
that i want to talk to you about 99 of
it is good uh obviously the big
news of today is that bob saget the
legendary comedian and actor and my
friend
my friend
passed away last night here in florida
in orlando so we'll get to that in a
little bit and a couple other stories i
just wanted to talk to you a bit about
what these last
couple weeks have been like because we
got
to florida on december 18th and
immediately david and i got covered my
whole team got covered we all got it in
la because we were basically sick pretty
much the first day that we got here and
as you know right before christmas
omicron was running rampant all over the
place i had some leg aches
my throat hurt a little bit i took some
ricola i drank some water i was okay it
hit david a little bit harder
michael got it conor did not get it
believe it or not oh and i should
mention michael is here in studio with
me right now connor is working remotely
so when i'm talking to people off camera
one of them may not even be in this room
that's the magic of television or the
internet or whatever it is that we're
doing here but anyway a bunch of covid
stuff happened so it was a little bit of
an odd start to florida in that regard
but
to florida's credit within a day of
getting coveted i was able to get a
monoclonal treatment i then took
ivermectin as well
which they tell you is horse paste but
it worked for me and i was pretty much
okay and then look everybody got covid i
think maybe this is how this whole thing
was supposed to end not that the powers
that be really want this thing to end
but the ending would be that sort of
everyone would get it it would be a
lesser variant that wouldn't send so
many people to the hospital people would
get sick but then it would sort of show
people like oh you got vaccinated and
boosted and you're
you know still sick and you didn't get
vaccinated or boosted and you're sick
and everyone's getting everybody sick
but we're all still basically here and
everything's basically okay like maybe
that is the ultimate ending to the to
the covet thing so we got to florida we
got kovid okay you know life goes on um
i did mention i did a video about having
kovid and uh you know i had never said
on this show
in these last two years of kovid mania i
had never said whether i was vaccinated
or not
my feeling was it's my own personal
decision that i was making with my
doctor and my family and my own my own
mind and i thought that's what i tell
everybody else they should be doing it
was irrelevant whether i was vaccinated
or not but once i got kobit i sort of
felt like i should say because
i wasn't that sick and even if i had
been very sick i think i still would
have said it so i am not vaccinated
i don't want to get kicked off youtube
for saying it but i'm 45 years old i'm
in relatively decent shape
and it was my choice not to as i said i
got the monoclonal got ivermectin took a
little advil a little ricola drank some
tea
all good all good anyway florida i just
have to say a few things about flour and
then we'll get to the top of the show as
you can see i'm excited to be back in
studio there's a lot going on in my mind
right now
being here for the last three weeks
has been a massive weight off my chest i
did not even realize how much being in
la and being in a sort of lockdown
you know covet obsessed masked
the madness of all of it i don't think i
fully realized how much it was affecting
me but right when i got off the plane
and i hope some of you guys saw the
video that we that we posted in the
reuben report community i we took uh
fortunate enough to have a friend who's
got a plane and we took a private flight
so that we didn't have to put clyde
under because he obviously can't keep a
dog on a normal plane without putting
them you know in the cargo area beneath
which we didn't want to do and i got to
sit in the cockpit as we were landing to
miami and i could feel i could really
like feel california like melting off of
me all of the nonsense all of the rules
and regulations and the high taxes and
all the
thinking about gavin newsom that that
evil freak had something to do with my
life all of that stuff like it melted
away from me and i have to say these
last few weeks even being sick for a
couple days have just been great there
is such incredible
energy here in miami specifically but
i've bounced around a little bit
throughout the state and people are
happy
people are smiling if you want to wear a
mask you wear a mask i've met so many
other refugees i've been to a couple
parties went to parties can you believe
it went to a new year's party all these
people that have moved here from
california from new york et cetera et
cetera and they know why they've moved
and they know why florida did it right
and that florida man who we all made fun
of and was a meme for all of these years
that florida man knew something that we
didn't know so i just want to be clear i
am here to keep florida florida i am
going to fight for it and if we can save
florida then maybe we can save america
and if we can maybe save america then
maybe we can save the world but it
starts here it really that's the way it
feels to me and i'm very excited oh and
i should mention before we get going
that so i go to this party like two or
three days
in to uh to the miami adventure and
mayor suarez who i've had on the show
who's the mayor of miami who's become
this real sort of magnet for the tech
people to come here and help businesses
and guys he's just a great guy
i get to this party and the mayor comes
up to me robin we're so happy to have
you gives me a big hug fist bump you
know going on and on about how excited
he is that i've moved my company here
and everything i was like man like think
how different that is than what i was
dealing with in california where
garcetti i don't know if he knew who i
was but certainly gavin newsom had me on
some kind of list and then
and we'll show you an image right now
i was invited to the governor's mansion
and i had dinner with that guy yeah the
guy who is basically single-handedly
saving the union ron desantis uh it was
myself a couple other uh influencers and
twitter people whatever it might be
carol markowitz and josh hammer and dave
reboy and couple of john cardio a couple
other people uh lisa booth it was just
great we had about five hours with the
governor just talking it was it was all
off the record so i'm not gonna say what
we were talking about specifically but
just
just to sit with this guy he is a good
decent man and he is ready to fight for
this place and governor desantis if
you're watching this
again i won't
repeat anything that was said off the
record but i want you to stay governor
of this state let's not worry about the
presidential thing i think that'll work
itself out uh because we got a state to
save so all that being said this is my
longest intro to a show ever uh i am i'm
reborn here i really feel like i am
reborn i'm psyched i'm very appreciative
to the newsmax guys for hooking us up in
this temporary studio for now we're
gonna build an awesome new studio at my
house we'll have a temporary studio
starting next week at my house and while
we build out the main studio but it's
just exciting to be here i'm i'm really
really thrilled uh and now i'm gonna
juxtapose that with story number one uh
which is that legendary comedian actor
and just freaking good decent man uh bob
saget has passed away at 65
years old uh bob was a good friend of
mine one of my best friends in the last
couple of years bob and his wife kelly
became great friends of david and i and
we were at their wedding actually the
picture that we're throwing up right now
that was at their wedding i was on tour
this was in 2018 it was the height of
the jordan peterson tour
and i was in england and bob's wedding
was coming up and i said you know i've
gotta get back for that like if you
don't
what's the purpose of success or
traveling or anything that you're doing
if you miss the real moments with people
right so i flew from uh london
to los angeles for one day to go to the
wedding and then i flew back to
amsterdam it was a crazy operation uh
but there's bob and kelly they're
they're just great people and i'm i'm
obviously very upset about this um i
want to show you just a quick about a
minute clip of uh bob
on the reuben report from about two
years ago and i think this sort of
really kind of captures who bob is to be
a good comic you have to have a ton of
[ __ ] like you have to have all this pain
and all this angst and all this stuff
but then at some point
you got to conquer it because otherwise
it'll conquer you and that's why so many
comics die of drug overdoses and all
this other stuff and
dying young
yeah but if you can own it then you
could be 62.
and i'm gonna be doing i don't know if
i'm gonna be doing stand up at 90 but
i'll be doing forms of it yeah you know
you couldn't stop even if you wanted to
right i could not stop working
i i i just directed this movie benjamin
which i'll talk about at length in the
third hour of our interview
but but i i have to leave after hour too
but you're welcome i'm going to stay
we're just going to keep going this
could be me and the camera but but i
i love working without it i
i i'm an artist
and it sounds so fruity pebbles to say
that but i just am and i always will be
and i'll be making whether it be
directing or writing or performing i
love acting
there's no limit as long as you can
stand and walk and bend and remember
things you know
you know yeah not fall into an open
trunk
right the memory one goes first because
now there's guys on broadway that are
using uh
earwigs yeah i was gonna say uh ibib
what's the intercontinental ibm
missiles yeah not those that's that's a
difference no no that has been known and
i hopefully will uh live long enough
that at 92 years old i'll be on broadway
and i'll have an airway again and
they'll feed me the lines and i don't
care
if i'm good if it's done right
oh god it's bittersweet to see that
i was just texting with bob a couple
days ago and two days ago he literally
posted this image on instagram i mean he
had just crushed it in orlando he was
doing stand-up again i mean does that
look like a 65 year old guy who is about
to die
so i don't know what happened uh
obviously more info will come out
uh it's irrelevant actually in a way the
world lost a great man a funny man you
know i've known a lot of comics in my
day and
comics love to make people laugh right
like that's it that's it more than
anything i've never met anyone who loved
to make people laugh more than bob saget
and he he donated to all sorts of
charities did all sorts of stuff on the
dl that nobody knew about and he was
just a good decent guy and we'll throw
up one other image here this was my
return to stand up a couple years ago
the way that bob
kelly david and i met was i did a
little show at the comedy store i hadn't
done stand-up for a couple years after
moving to l.a i did a little show at the
comedy store just to see if i could do
stand-up again and i and i really
crushed it and i get this message on
twitter from kelly bob's girlfriend at
the time and she says
oh you know we just saw you at the
comedy store you were upstairs and my
boyfriend you may have heard of him bob
sag it was downstairs in the big room
and uh you know we'd love to get
together for dinner we all quickly
became friends the image that you're
looking at there
was about a year later when i did the
irvine improv which is one of the
biggest comedy clubs in the country
certainly on the west coast and i did
about an hour myself
and then i brought bob on as a surprise
guest he he refused to take money he
then took my whole crew and family out
to dinner and he paid for it after uh he
was just a he was just a great guy he
was just a great guy and uh you know
obviously betty white also passed uh i
believe the last day of the year if i'm
not mistaken i think it was december
31st and she was sort of america's
grandmother like universally loved and
bob in some ways was america's dad right
full house
and uh
you know danny tanner and it's like
we don't have that many universally
loved people anymore that's what i was
thinking about this morning it's like
the the late night hosts we used to have
johnny carson people basically like
johnny carson now they're all so
polarized and all that and speaking of
the polarization part you know bob bob
and i didn't see eye to eye on all the
political stuff and i always used to
joke with him that we didn't have to
talk politics when we were having dinner
and he would always say he didn't want
to talk politics but then he would
always bring politics up but then
throughout the night we we would just
have a blast so the world lost a good
one
and
i love you bob and i'm gonna miss you
uh all right i want to talk to you guys
for just a minute we're gonna mix it up
for just a second i want to talk to you
guys for a moment about things that have
fundamentally changed the way we live
these are the disruptors things like
smartphones streaming services or dogs
named clyde who like to jump on you each
time you come home and clyde actually
did once jump on bob saget and punched
him in the nuts it's true
another disrupter i heard of recently is
a company called ladder who basically
took the life insurance industry flipped
it upside down and shook out the
inefficiencies before a ladder if you
wanted to get life insurance you had to
drive across town fill out a ton of
paperwork and then wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you've been
approved you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
your life insurance with things like car
insurance now with ladder you can get
fast affordable lifetime insurance
without leaving home it's a hundred
percent digital when you apply for three
million dollars or less in coverage no
doctors no needles no paperwork so if
you're between the ages of 20 to 60 need
coverage and want to team up with a
company that's redeeming life insurance
choose ladder the process is super quick
and easy go to ladderlife.com ruben
today to see if you are instantly
approved that's
ladderlife.comrubenladderlife.com
ruben and now back to me
all right so let's uh come back to
florida here for just a moment because
florida is free ron desantis who is the
governor here and his great attorney
general and his great surgeon general
they have decided almost from beat one
two years ago when it was two weeks to
flatten the curve that they were going
to keep the state open they were going
to give as much choice to people as
possible which is obviously
how this should have been managed and
again as i said at the top right now
here in florida if you want to wear a
mask you can but they're not going to
force you to do it they're not going to
force you to be injected with things
it's your choice and you know the good
liberals used to believe in choice
my body my choice not so much anymore
anyway florida has been open and florida
is booming there are all sorts of
metrics on this in terms of the way the
economy is exploding i can assure you uh
having just bought a house that the
house prices are blowing up the market
is crazy uh the amount of influx in
terms of tourists and people that are
coming here and the whole the whole
state it's just it's an exciting place
to be it truly is and it's so exciting
that aoc
you know this woman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
or as gadsad calls her alexandria
occasional cortex
she vacationed over the christmas break
here in miami so here's a picture of aoc
in florida she's drinking what looks to
be a martini in the middle of the day
that apparently is her boyfriend over
there and uh originally this image
got viral through steve cortez who
tweeted it out and made a comment about
the boyfriend's feet because he's
wearing those flip-flops with the socks
okay so be it that's just fine
that is sort of irrelevant to the fact
that aoc
who has locked down her people who has
been all about mandates who does not
vote in congress in person she has
someone do it by proxy because of the
pandemic okay this is someone who in
essence has been a lockdown ho okay
that's when i called her on twitter and
now i'm saying it live
she has decided that she would vacation
in florida this is someone who i have no
doubt has said horrible things about ron
desantis has said horrible things about
florida but they are all and this is the
key part guys and we all just need to
know it and then what you do with it is
up to you these politicians and aoc
ain't the only one who do one thing
privately and who lock down their people
publicly and then vacation elsewhere in
the places that they say are the
scariest things
they are [ __ ] artists
and they're not very good artists
they're just extraordinary bullshitters
so aoc
comes to miami which miami is open and
the weather is good and people are out
and there are crowds and she's having
drinks outside and she's not social
distancing all of that stuff and then
she went to a drag bar on miami beach
and we've got some video
[Applause]
[Music]
good god it could make you puke i mean
these ridiculous people applauding her
applauding her why would you be
applauding this woman you live in
florida or are vacationing to florida
south beach obviously big tourist area
you are all living and or vacationing
here because it's open because it's good
because they haven't destroyed all of
the businesses
be they drag bars or shoe repair shops
and these fools that are applauding her
and she she's there she's hugging people
obviously not social distancing or
masking or any of that stuff they don't
even believe
their own [ __ ] and that's all it is
so then after ao aoc started getting a
lot of crap for this
she tweeted this out if republicans are
mad they can't date me they can just say
that instead of projecting their sexual
frustrations onto my boyfriend's feet
you creepy weirdos it's starting to get
old ignoring the very obvious strange
and deranged sexual frustrations that
underpin the republican fixation on me
women and lgbt plus people in general
these people clearly need therapy won't
do it and use their politics as an
outlet instead it's really weird i mean
everything she just said there i assure
you i have no sexual frustrations
related to aoc okay
number one number two everything she
just said there is just pure projection
her politics are a projection of her own
desire to run people's lives run
people's world make sure that they have
to abide by her laws while she does not
the people that nobody was really
attacking over her over her boyfriend's
feet nobody cares about his pasty white
feet and his flip-flops and by the way i
don't mind the sock flip-flop thing i've
been known to do it used to live in west
hollywood there were a lot of russians
there that's what they do because it was
cold in russia and then they come to
california it's a little warmer because
you're the sock and the flip-flop i
don't mind it michael's nodding his head
you don't do it but i do do it every now
and again okay is what it is my
frustration with aoc is that she is an
abject fraud she's a fraud and i'm
someone that lives in the state that you
come in to enjoy yourself while you lock
people down i'm not kidding when i say
this i think florida should pass a law
in texas as well in tennessee and some
of the other red states if you are a
lockdown ho like aoc if you are a
politician who locks down your own
people and forces mandates on people and
everything else you cannot come here i
think the states are going to really
have to think about things like that you
cannot come here like if you move to
america you have to kind of dig america
right you have to
know some things about america you have
to know some stuff about our history you
have to be able to recite the national
anthem etc etc aoc hates america that's
obvious but she hates florida
in the public sense but privately
actually loves florida sorry you
shouldn't be allowed to come here
anymore i'm going to talk to
governor desantis about that oh and then
it gets even better
it gets even better because life
finds a way
uh aoc got covered yeah so here's a
tweet from aoc's official account
representative ocasio-cortez has
received a positive test result for
covid19 she is experiencing symptoms and
recovering at home the congresswoman
received her booster shot this fall and
encourages everyone to get their booster
and follow all cdc guidance okay so
she's just a ridiculous clown i'm
running out of adjectives for this woman
because she wasn't following cdc
guidelines right maskless out hugging
people huge crowds blah blah blah
vacationed in a place that allows you to
do all that and then if the vaccines
worked and the booster worked then would
she have got covid we'll do more on that
in just a moment but she did all the
stuff right she took all the vaccines
she still got covered so and i will just
add one other thing i don't wish anyone
uh ill i don't want her to be sick as
much as i don't like her
but perhaps perhaps maybe
if enough of us point out her hypocrisy
she will wake up to some of this
so we
shall
see
uh you know when we were picking the
stories
for this week uh for today specifically
it was like i've missed out on a couple
weeks i'm like how much should we do
about florida how much we do about some
of these other cities and states and
then there was just such a plethora of
craziness coming out of all of these
other states that we had to do something
from my old hometown of new york city
because new york city has a new mayor
his name is eric adams and the media has
sort of been framing this guy as a
moderate he's not like full-on lefty
socialist maniac bill de blasio he's a
moderate and he's going to be pro-police
and he's going to be for cleaning up the
city and doing something about the
homelessness and the drug use and all of
that stuff that's the way it was framed
well then this past weekend yesterday
sunday
eric adams went on jake tapper's show on
the entertainment network cnn
and started talking about allowing
non-citizens to vote in new york city
you announced last night that you're
going to support a law passed last month
in new york city which will allow
roughly 800 000
legal
non-citizens to vote in local elections
provided that they've lived in new york
for at least 30 days you previously
called the bill problematic and
expressed concern about giving a right
to vote to non-citizens who've only been
here for a short amount of time why did
you change your mind and why is it
acceptable for non-citizens to vote in
an american election
no i did not change my mind i supported
the concept of the bill the one aspect
of that i had a problem with and i
thought was problematic was the 30-day
part of being in the country for 30 days
was the place that i had questions and i
sat down with my colleagues i'm a big
believer in conversation we have to
start talking to each other and not at
each other and after hearing their
rationale and their theories behind it i
thought it was more important to not
veto the bill or get in the way at all
and allow the bill to move forward
doesn't the bill just make a mockery of
the idea of american citizenship though
i mean this is just for local elections
but does that mean like next uh new york
city is going to want non-citizens to
vote in federal elections i mean
what do you say to all the people who
went through the process the difficult
process of becoming an american citizen
studying for the test swearing an oath
of allegiance to the united states of
america who who now see this legislation
just saying well anyone who's here all
right so first off i'll give credit
where credit is due although i don't
think jake tapper is great and he is
basically a democrat operative
pretending to be a journalist he
sometimes does get some things right i'd
say he's he bats like a hundred he's
like one out of ten he gets some things
right so his questions were good there
eric adams just said complete nonsense
and lies there so he was basically like
oh i was sort of always for this i was
concerned about the 30-day thing but
then once i sat down and heard the
activists theories well then i realized
30 days in the country yeah you can vote
in new york city think how really crazy
this is and i i lived in new york city
from about 2000 to 2015.
uh so most of my adult life actually i
was living in new york city i was in new
york city for 9 11.
i loved new york city right if you can
make it there you can make it anywhere
like new york city should be the best
place on earth it is it is a far cry
from that right now this man is saying
that 800 000 people who are not legally
here in this country who do not deserve
the rights and privileges of being an
american that they can vote in the city
and his whole thing was oh but i i
didn't want the 30-day thing like if you
were here for 31 days then it would be
okay
but really think about what he's saying
that means if you can just figure out
how to get in through mexico and you
just make it to new york city and you're
here for
four weeks basically right one month you
can vote you can actually influence
elections and influence policy over
people who have been here this entire
time you look people you gotta leave
blue cities you really should leave blue
states if you're saying but you've got
to leave the big cities because more and
more of this nonsense is coming and this
guy was framed as the moderate he was
the one that was going to back the
police now we see that kind of going
away he was the one that was going to
make sure that you weren't going to have
this nonsense also the way jake tapper
framed it i just gave him credit but now
i'll take a little credit away he calls
them legal non-citizens the legal
non-citizens do you see the orwellian
language that these people use it's
really extraordinary but adams already
has a corruption scandal on his head
we've got some info from the daily news
mayor adams went on the defensive sunday
over prominent appointments for his own
brother and a former high-ranking cop
implicated in a bribery scandal he said
his office was seeking a waiver from the
city's conflicts of interest board to
allow sibling bernard adams to take a
high-ranking nypd job after the brother
had already joined the city payroll so
he's basically making his brother who is
unqualified from another state a
high-ranking
person in the new york police department
so it's like this is what these people
do and i am sorry to my few sane liberal
friends who are left who thought they
were getting the moderate and thought
that the crazy socialist bill de blasio
was on his way out and the city was
going to turn around these people it's
just like la it's like california they
want more corruption they want more
lawlessness they want more illegals
voting they don't want people to show
ids when they're voting like it's so
it's all so crazy that the answer in my
estimation isn't oh let me stay here and
fix it the answer is to do what i did
and to take your skills if you're
watching this from new york city if
you're watching this from la take your
skills your passion your family
the value that you bring to the world
and find a place that is in line with
your views
but aoc you can't come here want to be
very clear about that you cannot come
here uh one of the other big stories
over the last week or so
was the appearance by dr robert malone
on the joe rogan podcast
and he talked about something called
mass formation psychosis which i'll let
him explain in just a moment
but we all sort of know what it is right
like if you say the phrase mass
formation psychosis it's mass it's a lot
formation it's something that's kind of
moving psychosis a little craziness sort
of what we all can sort of tell without
being experts has been happening over
the last two years right everyone is
just sort of nuts and nothing is really
true or real or at least you got to
really try to pilfer some reality out of
all of the nonsense and that the people
in charge say joe biden
dr fauci et cetera have lied to us all
along so before we get into mass
formation psychosis i'm going to show
you some lies we've got a compilation
during 2021 we should be able to
manufacture a lot of vaccines and and
that vaccine
a key goal is to stop the transmission
to get the immunity levels up so that
you get almost no almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever
everyone who takes the vaccine is not
just protecting themselves but reducing
their transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal we can kind of almost
see the end we're we're vaccinating so
very fast our data from the cdc today
suggests um you know that that
vaccinated people do not carry the virus
don't get sick now we know that the
vaccines work well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person a
vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else it cannot use a vaccinated
person as a host to go get more people
that means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this essentially vaccines
block you from getting and giving um the
virus fully vaccinated people
are at a very very low risk of getting
covet 19.
therefore
if you've been fully vaccinated
you no longer need to wear a mask when
people are vaccinated they can feel safe
that they are not going to get infected
we have all the vaccines we need
we just need our people to take it
a for their own protection for the
protection of their family
but also to break the chain of
transmission you want to be a dead end
to the virus so when the virus gets to
you
you stop it you don't allow it to use
you
as the stepping stone to the next person
okay so everything that those people to
that catchy tune
were telling you there over the last two
years was basically a lie or complete
misinformation or disinformation or they
didn't know what they were talking about
or they're
misinforming you lying whatever phrase
you want to use for political purposes
or something but these are the people in
charge right this is joe biden does he
know what he's saying or is he just
handed a script and he reads it or is he
intentionally lying was fouchy lying
when he said that my favorite one is uh
the actress on msnbc rachel maddow
because she reads off the teleprompter
with such
certitude such she's so sure of exactly
what she's reading and that's exactly
what's going to happen and she sits
there and it's msnbc and she's very sure
of something that's completely wrong
completely wrong so these people have
lied and misinformed all of us all and
what's interesting think about i do a
daily show here right i do a five day a
week show how come i didn't lie about
all that stuff this whole time how come
i was like hey if you want to get it get
it maybe we should have some more info
talk to your doctor make a choice for
yourself so when you see all these lies
all the time don't pretend that everyone
lied all along and we're gonna have to
think about when this is all done when
this is all done and one day it will be
what do we do with these people like i'm
not for throwing them in the gulag like
they'd love to do with us but should
they be like sort of shamed out of
public society bill gates what does bill
gates have to do with all of our public
health congratulations for creating
paint on windows in 1995 great guy bill
gates where you don't run my life
anywho it gets even better here's cdc
director wolensky you know this woman
we've shown many clips of her
she's basically admitting that the
vaccine just don't work
our vaccines are working exceptionally
well they continue to work well for
delta with regard to severe illness and
death they prevent it but what they
can't do anymore is prevent transmission
so if you're going home to somebody who
has not been vaccinated to somebody who
can't get vaccinated somebody who might
be immunosuppressed or a little bit fail
frail somebody who has um
comorbidities that put them at high risk
i would suggest you wear a mask in
public indoor settings
oh lady okay so they work well but they
don't prevent transmission what's also
interesting is they not only don't
prevent transmission
but we know that it doesn't really
matter if you're relatively young and
healthy whether you're vaccinated or not
and you get covered because people are
recovering especially from the omicron
variant i know plenty of people who were
vaccinated who had kova the exact same
time as me and they kept saying because
they've been vaccinated and i i got the
two vaccines and i was boosted and i had
87 shots and everything else it didn't
hit me that hard right like so that's
their own version of it that's the thing
that everybody as elizabeth warren and
cory booker and as all of these public
people have gotten it and i'm sure aoc
is going to say the same thing i got the
boosters i did what i was supposed to do
i got shot so i didn't get that sick
well there are plenty of people who
didn't do those things who figured out
other treatments right or maybe just
took some advil whatever it is that they
decided to do who also aren't that sick
so there's no real any any evidence on
any of that but the very people who are
telling us that masks work are now
telling us masks don't work the people
who are telling us that the vaccine
stops transmission and you can then go
out and live your life are now telling
us the complete reverse and that brings
me to mass formation psychosis so dr
robert malone was on the joe rogan
podcast and he is one of the creators of
the mrna vaccine and he went on for a
couple hours i'm sure many of you have
seen some clips of this already and he
talked about what is happening here not
really at the disease level but what is
happening to all of us collectively
mentally take a look basically european
intellectual inquiry into what the heck
happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
um and how did that happen um
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has free
floating anxiety in a sense that things
don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events on one small point just
like hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
and one of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as
their leaders the ones typically that
come in and say you have this pain and i
can solve it for you i and i alone
okay can fix this problem for you okay
then they will lead they will follow
that person through it doesn't matter
whether they lie to him or whatever the
data are irrelevant and furthermore
anybody who questions
that narrative is to be immediately
attacked they are the other
is central to mass formation psychosis
and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before
2019 everybody was complaining the world
doesn't make sense blah blah blah
um and we're all isolated from each
other we're all on our little tools
we're not connected socially anymore
except through social media
um and then this thing happened and
everybody focused on it
that is how mass formation psychosis
happens and that is what's happened here
who sounds more truthful dr robert
malone as he calmly explains that one of
the founders of mrna technology someone
who is a complete expert on uh what we
are all injecting ourselves with right
does he sound more honest or is it
rachel maddow reading off the
teleprompter is it joe joe rogan is it
joe biden
rogan's fine is it biden as he is
reading whatever they put in front of
him etc etc i think you guys know the
answer to that now i'm not going to sit
here and pretend that i'm an expert in
mass formation psychosis but malone's
pretty close to it and over the last two
years i think i have spent most of my
time on this show i think probably the
main reason you watch the show is to
pilfer some of that sanity from all of
the [ __ ] all of the lies that are
constantly thrown at us right brett
kavanaugh as a serial rapist the
covington kids are all racist kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist
murder donald trump said very fine
people on both sides russia hoax like
all of this stuff that can cause a mass
formation psychosis a bunch of
misinformation fed to us from the
machine
that you then see something you might
find some little clip some crazy guy
online who might be able to counter some
of that information but you're the one
that feels crazy for having seen it
because so much of the machine is just
about peddling [ __ ] to control you
and mandate you do this and decide when
you can go out and everything else if
there has ever been a case of mass
formation psychosis in modern times this
is it and the way he talked about nazi
germany
people didn't just become nazis
overnight people didn't just turn on
their neighbors overnight
it was slow remember that video we did a
couple weeks ago jordan peterson also on
joe rogan's show talking about inch by
inch that's how they get you they don't
just get you overnight they get you inch
by inch well we're two years after two
weeks to flatten the curve so anyway it
is obvious to me whether the technical
definition of mass formation psychosis
is fully applicable or not is irrelevant
the concept of it is clearly right there
has been something very wrong we all
know about the lies and and we know how
many people are are suffering a
psychosis because of the lies because
their own reality doesn't match up with
the lies so when they're told oh if you
get the vaccine you're totally safe and
you're not going to transmit and blah
blah blah and then has happened to quite
literally hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people in the last two weeks
that were double vaccine boosts and
everything else they started getting
coveted well then they start freaking
out what is true what is true so maybe
the red pills are being dulled out at a
very high level right now anyway i bring
all of this up because then the best
part of all of this is that the
associated press then fact checked mass
formation psychosis because too many
people started talking about it
and they said mass formation psychosis
an unfounded theory spreading online
suggests millions of people have been
hypnotized into believing mainstream
ideas to combat covid19 psychology
experts say the concept is not supported
by evidence get the facts ap oh thank
you thank you ap for that that seems
very truthful and honest
we are in a [ __ ] factory guys but
we're in it together and i now live in
florida and i am more committed than
ever to fight for truth and reason and
freedom and individual rights
i'm psyched to be back in studio uh so
man we are going to fight the mass
formation psychosis that's the mission
and i'm gonna do it from sunny
free florida that is the plan going
forward i want to just thank once again
the newsmax folks for letting us borrow
the studio this week i want to thank the
blaze folks who were going to let us use
the studios over in dallas but as i said
i felt like i just had to be in florida
this week i want to thank my whole team
that has moved here
not everyone's even in their houses and
apartments yet like it's been it's been
a little janky getting here and getting
everybody in order but we're all coming
together now
we should close out on the house this
week so by next week we'll be in a
temporary studio in the house we're
going to build out state of the art
studios and spare no expense i am super
psyched to be here i also want to say
it's been so refreshing meeting people
here when i went to whole foods
yesterday in target a couple of times
and just walking down the street and i
could wear my let's go brandon t-shirt
and people smile and give me high-fives
and everyone's been so nice
and i truly i said it before but i feel
reborn i feel something has been lifted
off of my chest and i hope that if you
are in a place that is not
aligned with what you believe it is not
aligned with the life that you want to
live think about your life seriously no
one's coming to save you but you can
save yourself
and there are places
that are beacons for freedom right now
so all right as you can tell i'm psyched
to be back i'm psyched to be in florida
oh and i and i also just want to thank
you guys you know when we moved uh
december 18th or so i thought we were
going to close on the house a couple
days before christmas i was planning on
being in the studio a little bit before
christmas it ended up being a sort of a
three-week slog here um and i missed you
guys i really did like every day i was
sending stories to michael like i want
to be in the studio to talk about this
that and the other thing there's just so
much going on um so i just want to thank
all of you who support me you know i i
when we did the goodbye video from
florida that last thing that we did in
the studio i went into the comment
section and like so many people just
wishing me luck and happy for me and
planning to do the same thing
and it is not lost so i want to thank
all of you who are watching i especially
want to thank
all of the members over at
rubinreport.locals.com that's where i
respond to people every day and i'm
getting to know you guys and i just love
it i'm psyched florida man it's awesome
have a great day everybody we'll be back
tomorrow